(upbeat intro music playing)
- [Kelly] Wanna come sit over here?
- Do I sit here?
- I think you switch.
But I'm really... is that a horse?
Wait, what's happening in that necklace?
Oh, it is a horse!
- It is a horse!
- [Kelly] That's beautiful!
It's an opal horse
from Australia.
- [Kelly] Ooh, beautiful.
- I know.
- [Kelly] I just love
the simplicity of it, the design.
- Thank you!
- Very nice, whoever created that.
So we were talking about Christmas.
Any big plans for you for Christmas?
You have a big family.
- I have a big family.
Every year, we do this ugly
sweater Christmas competition,
which we're prepping for right now.
Oh my god. It's so brutal.
- I just love that your family competes.
I love them already.
- [Poppy] They compete hardcore.
So you go to the 99 cent store,
you buy as much ugly
stuff as you can find.
- Good filter, yeah!
- [Poppy] Sorry.
(Kelly laughing)
And you make your sweaters.
You're not allowed to buy them.
They can't be like the
pre-done kind of Target or-
- You mean like knit
them, or you can actually?
- No, you don't have to!
- Okay, that's going to
take a long time. Wow!
- Go to Michael's or, yeah,
JoAnn's and go nuts, yeah.
- You get like a bad, sort of, sweater
that you can hot glue gun and off you go.
And all ages compete,
and we have people over,
and there's cash prizes
to make it more brutal.
- I love your family.
- Oh, but my kids, I cry if I don't win.
(Linda laughing)
I actually have some of the
sweaters from last year.
- Oh my god, wait, I heard
about this. I want to see them.
Justin has them.
- Oh!
- So these are some of your.
(audience applauding)
Wait, so let's see your, I love this!
- Here's the thing, I'm not
going to tell you which is mine.
But I lost last year, and I cried.
I drank a bottle of vodka,
and I was very upset.
I was voted out.
- Oh my gosh!
- So I just, if you guys want to choose
which one you think should
have won, then we'll see.
- We're picking the best one?
- No pressure!
- Or picking the ugliest one?
- It's the best ugly Christmas sweater.
- Like, the one you would
wear or the one you are...?
- The one you would never ever wear, like.
- That's the one I want to wear, yeah.
- I might want to wear them
all though, is that bad?
- And they flash! You
can buy all kinds of,
okay, so this one.
- [Kelly] This is pretty great.
This is pretty great. I love that.
- And then he's one on the back.
- [Kelly] Aww!
- [Linda] And a bird?
- Look, two birds on the shoulders,
its a little couture.
- Okay, I see how you're
selling this one, okay, okay.
- Now this one, don't look too closely.
(Kelly laughing)
(audience laughing)
- Oh!
- I have a favorite!
(all laughing)
I already picked my favorite.
- Okay.
- [Linda] That's amazing.
- Now, I have this, this is bit heavier.
- Let me get this for you.
- Of course.
- I love this.
- This has detail, and I'm not.
A lot of effort went into this sweater.
- Can I stand up?
- [Kelly] Yes!
- 'Cause there's a whole thing to this.
- Santa stop here?!
- Yeah!
(audience laughing and applauding)
- [Kelly] Oh my god.
- [Poppy] There's his house.
- Yes.
- It jingles!
- It jingles.
- It jingles. I see how
you're selling this one.
- I feel like she's really
selling this one like this one
might be yours.
- Yeah!
Here's the reason why I didn't
think this was gonna be beat
until Santa stopped there.
(Kelly laughing)
- Which would you pick?
- I think, I think the first one maybe?
- Okay. I'm taking Santa stops here.
(Poppy laughing)
- Okay, I got one. And then
Gus, my eight year old.
- Yeah, I do like-
- Gus, an eight year old.
- Oh my god, really?!
- He made this one.
- [Kelly] That's great!
- No, he doesn't get
to win because he's eight!
- No, I wasn't saying because he's eight,
I actually like, I'm
impressed that he did it.
That's like, I mean,
that's a lot of gluing.
- I might've helped.
- [Kelly] You might've helped?
(all talking over each other)
I was like, I don't know.
(audience cheering)
So, all our daughters
are named after flowers.
My Daughter's River Rose.
- Mine's Lyla Rose.
- Rose in my family, it was
because it was a family,
it was in our family.
- Ours, we know people
with the name and I always have
loved people with that name,
and it just flowed beautifully, so.
The first name we didn't have for a while
but we had that part.
- Okay. Lyla's beautiful.
- And then Kinko's gave
us ideas for names.
(audience laughing)
(Kelly laughing)
And we picked that one!
- That's incredible! How does,
and your daughter's name?
- Violet.
- [Kelly] Violet, I love that.
- Grace. And then all the
girls in my family are flowers.
So we have Rosie Thorn,
Daisy Yellow, Marigold Sun,
Lily Bell and I'm Poppy Petal.
- Do your parents like marijuana?
(all laughing)
- We asked that!
We're like, my brother's
name is Jethro Tull!
- I just brought it up,
just to bring it up!
- I was like, were you
high, were you stripping?
And not that many times.
She had all the babies!
- Not that many times!
- [Poppy] Not too many times!
- Not while pregnant! I just love that,
that's, I'm obsessed
with plants and flowers.
My kids actually hate them
because I love them so much.
- [Poppy] Right.
- Yeah, they're like,
that and books, they're like, ugh!
- Thank you! Not one of
my children reads. Nope.
- Oh they read. Not by choice!
- No, not by choice!
- It's forced family fun at our house.
(Linda laughing)
So, any boys in your
family named after flowers?
- So, no, I, you know it's interesting,
we're always working on the name thing,
I have five kids, and, erm.
- That's a lot, do you
need a glass of wine, or?
- I drink it all the time.
- [Linda] How did you have
any time for these sweaters?!
- That's why I came up
with it, I was like,
you know what, I'm gonna get, this is
something we can do as a family!
- [Kelly] Forced family fun!
- But my son Jackson,
his last name is Koffman,
he's got a different dad than
my other kids. Long story.
When I was about to give birth
to him, we revealed his name
to his grandparents,
and we said, you know,
we're gonna call him Jack.
- Cute name.
- Cute name. Love Jack, simple, classic.
And his grandfather Harvey was like,
"You can't call that kid Jack.",
And I was like, why?
- What?
- And he said his last name is Koffman,
and I was like, so? And he said,
"Say Jack Koffman three times fast."
- Jack Koff... Oh, (beep)!
- [Poppy] Jack Koffman,
Jack Koffman, Jack Koffman.
- Santa stop here!
(all laughing)
- I was like, what's
wrong with Jack Koffman?
(audience applauding)
- Yeah, Jack Koffman!
- Oh my god.
- He's gonna kill me for telling you.
- I truly love your family!
- It's like one mishap after another,
I was like, I didn't mean
to call you Jack Koffman!
- Oh my god!
- I didn't have much time,
'cause it was scheduled
c-section and I just said
let's just call him Jackson, and no one
can shorten his name ever.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That's it, it's Jackson.
- That's cute. Yeah.
- And Jackson's cute, we like Jackson.
But no one's allowed to
call him Jackson, it's like,
"No, no, no, no!".
- Yeah, now that you've said
it aloud and I did as well, no!
Nope!
- Nope!
- Let's talk about Christmas On The Farm.
So it's actually based on something
that happened to you, right?
- Yes. My mother passed
away unexpectedly in 2019.
- I'm so sorry.
- [Poppy] Yeah.
It was very jarring. And I,
she went out to feed the horses
and died, so it's a cheerful Christmas
movie premise already I'm like, well.
But I inherited a farm
in Australia and came up
with this idea of... I
wanted to do a movie that
was a tribute to her and
the farm that I inherited
that I don't know how to exist on, I mean,
animals hate me,
attack me.
- Oh, you're like more city?
- Oh my god, like.
- I'm opposite.
I would love your farm!
- We could switch, because it's like
city mouse and country
mouse, I was like, every time
I go to the farm, the
horse, we have horses,
Captain and Tennille, they bite me.
- Oh!
- Gregory Peck, our rooster.
- I was gonna say!
- Yeah, Gregory pecks me,
so I put it all in to
this movie and it became
about my mom, it's a
Christmas movie that starts
with a funeral, but it's
actually quite funny
and charming, it really is!
- I love that you led with,
"It's a Christmas movie
that starts with a funeral."
- I just don't want anyone
to be thrown when they start
watching it, it's like, oh!
- You know what though?
That's real though.
Things happen, or even people
experiencing Christmas.
Like, I know people that,
even this Christmas,
this'll be their first
Christmas without a loved one
that they've had in their life.
- Right.
- That's a real thing
that happens and it's relatable.
- It is, and I was like, you know,
for people who have lost
someone at Christmas,
we are sort of representing
that in this film.
Plus, we show what an
Australian Christmas looks like!